they're in entertainment their parents
ain't want them to do that let's be
honest yeah like being an actor that's
not what your parents are like hoping
you would be when you grow up
so they're renegades as well but because
you're too
rent you're too much of a renegade
they're like oh no but that's a little
too full
he shits in the back of his prius they
don't want that [ __ ] no no that's
understandable
i'm okay with that like you should be
shunned by the community
like chinese people just stop [ __ ]
on the street and here you are
an asian sitting in a prius not on
purpose by accident what happened
you don't even drink i got no excuses i
know i just have this
i i i smoke cigarettes and i drink a lot
of coffee andrew
right i have this certain urgent i have
a certain urge
to take a [ __ ] every once in a while
uncontrollably traffic or like
what's the word park outside of my
dermatologist because
he would rather [ __ ] inside the car than
outside and occur oh my god bro
on la cienega you can't [ __ ] outside of
los angeles it's the busiest street in
l.a yeah so you [ __ ] in your prius like
[ __ ] in the prius
in a bag in a bag in a bag oh yeah seat
yeah i didn't think you shouldn't
[ __ ] see
yeah yeah but he has shot in the seat
before i have done that too
yeah so many stories
but here's the thing okay that
wow what why what why didn't you do you
never had a
sudden urge to take a [ __ ] and you had
no control over i've shed my pants
before well there we go i don't want to
[ __ ] in my own pants i was sad
oh you're a sexy i'm not being an adult
[ __ ] in my pants i don't know
three times a day at least oh you do i
like the [ __ ] yeah
i should have to push or does it come
out like slide out no it comes out
yeah i'm good to go three meals three
shits that's how i do it do you take
long shits or short ones longer
30 mins but you're so you're conditioned
to [ __ ] at a certain time is that what
it is nope
you force it nope what it just happens
organically oh you sometimes i'll do
three shits before 3 p.m
are you being real swear to god in my
life is it worth my life
are you taking anything for that drink
um mct oil
none of it no nothing it just happens i
get a good workout in we're taking shits
yeah yeah i mean i [ __ ] in my hand the
other day for what
would you do why yeah for what reason
why
i don't know about this one i know i
didn't tell you it was so and then it
was the bathroom was a disaster
why did you do in your hand though oh
god
all right yeah you're gonna tell us i'm
going to but i have to there's got to be
an angle
okay can i find my angle yeah okay [ __ ]
you man you white piece of [ __ ]
yeah you white pieces all right you only
have one
[Laughter]
you see what is happening here yeah yeah
he cares if you get corona
from him he doesn't care if you get
caught
he's welcoming the corona he could
easily put another one of those little
what is it cardboard box is that what
that is yeah this is unbelievable okay
so you grabbed a piece of [ __ ] like
a [ __ ] no like a red ass i cupped the
phone
you tried i cupped a fart okay
ah you know how you cut the fart yeah
and then so what
okay so like last night i was really
gassy no remember one fart i had
and you were like what the [ __ ] is that
yeah right i
apologize okay good yeah look at me i
apologize
let's disgusting disgusting you cupped a
fart in front of her
i always do at night so what i do is i
don't want her to know that i'm farting
okay
right so i'll do a cup and then right no
and then i'll take
my pinky and my thumb yep and i'll
spread the cheeks open a little bit like
this so it comes out so it comes out
with no noise yeah yep
done that yeah yeah and it's my it's my
style of doing it yeah it's great
thank you so much andrew honestly i
completely understand right so i so the
the other nice it's respectful it's like
you actually care about her you don't
want bingo
yeah bingo right so i i spread it open
and i come to fart
and then when i looked at my hand in the
bed it was a pile of [ __ ]
oh you didn't feel it at first you just
saw it yeah oh wow
right but then i felt i felt like you
know my hand went
clung yeah you're like a cartoony clung
yeah right
yeah i looked at it are you okay
what's the angle there's no angle i'm
just i'm telling a straight story
i couldn't find an egg
i'm just embarrassed all right so what
it was and then so i had to do like a um
i think i was a waiter right i was a
waiter for years
right so i had to do a what's
all right i apologize babe okay right so
like i had to do a waiter thing
yeah you know i mean like i was in perry
you know what i mean yeah and i had like
you know i mean
a coffee yeah you know i mean i had to
do a thing
and i threw it in the [ __ ] toilet oh
yeah yeah
and then i washed my hands but i looked
on the ground there was a trail so i had
to clean it up it was a [ __ ]
what is wrong with you yes yeah i have a
lot of things wrong and i sh and
let me say something yeah that was
something that i was gonna die
with yeah because i came in the room and
i was like why does it smell like [ __ ]
in here okay
no yeah with that story right i wasn't
gonna [ __ ] say it right yeah
but i kept the [ __ ] there's a real poo
right now in the living room it's not
youtube that wasn't me
that was a dog there's a way what was it
[Music]
yeah there's a robot there's a rogue poo
up there and i looked at it too
and i it wasn't me hey guys we're going
to take a very quick break to share
some of our favorite sponsors with you
better help
[Music]
yeah you guys um i don't know what i
would do
without better help during this pandemic
because it's helped kalella and i
immensely therapy has
is there something interfering with your
happiness or is preventing you